So how do we do Radiometric Calibration?
Again, we're interested in this
pipeline of going from L towards I,
but we also want to be able to
model the inverse phenomenon of it.
So let's start off with a Color Chart,
that we know the reflectances of.
What basically means is a color chart
like this comes in predefined and
here basically, just I'm showing
you the gray values here.
It shows what are the intensities,
90, 59.1%.
So somebody had sat down and
calibrated this color chart as a perfect
color model or gray scale values
that we're interested in.
What we want to do is we want to
take multiple exposures from this
co, color chart.
Which basically means is I'm
going to take images of this.
What I can do of course is I can take
them at different exposure values.
That basically means I can, you know,
do things like ep, epsilon photography.
I can take images at different
exposures, shutter speeds, and
all that kind of stuff.
That would of course change how,
what kind of intensities for
the same image that is out there.
Of course, we're basically playing
around on this parameter here to oh,
different types of parameters
to get to this value.
I'm just showing you an example of this.
So, again,
my pixel values go from zero to 55.
This is my scene irradiance.
I'm going to look at irradiance, because
we know scene radiance to ir, irradiance
is a linear things and actually we're
more interested in trying to get there.
This mapping is something
which is linear.
Of course, when done,
we know what's going on.
Of course, this basically means is now
everything's projected on a 2D surface,
which the information is coming from.
So, of course, if I know the scene
irradiance I can plot a point,
as I go at different scene irradiance.
And of course I can figure out from
this one what is the intensity at each
and every pixel.
So next part that we can do now, of
course, is after I've drawn this curve,
for a specific device or a sensor,
and imaging device like the camera
I've done this on by taking in this
case, one image, two image, three, four,
five, six, seven images and
I can basically fill in the curve.
Now I can do the opposite, right.
If I know a pixel value, or I want to,
curious about a pixel value,
can I actually now compute
the scene irradiance?
And that's what this
exercise basically shows.
Once I can model this, I can always
come back and I say, okay, what's here?
I can figure out the scene
irradiance at this point.
Again, scene irradiance here
is going from zero to one.
Now, this will allow me to
pick up any values I want.
So, of course,
there are few assumptions here, in,
when we play around
with images like this.
It assumes constant lighting,
and all patches,
basically, are equally well lit.
So it can't be a focused light source.
The assumes of light source
is really far away, and
is equally lighting the whole scene.
So, you know, for example,
something like natural sunlight.
When you light with this kind of
stuff we're allowed to do this.
A unique inverse exists for
g because in this case g is monotonic
and smooth for all types of cameras.
And again we will model this for
different cameras and
this allows us to compute this.